Speaker 1: So I want to start today talking
about inflation, we are now starting to see
inflation rise more quickly than it has in
quite some time, and Republicans are going
absolutely crazy, thinking that this vindicates
their 30 years of claims that, oh, no, now
the government has done some stimulus.
We are going to see this inflationary spiral
which will destroy the economy.
They've been saying it for 30 years and it
hasn't happened.
And now they are turning this recent new employment
inflation number, not employment number, into
what they claim is a vindication of the claims
they've been making for the last 30 years.
And somehow this also relates to Joe Biden.
And we're going to get back to that in a moment.
But I think it's important to understand the
kind of context here the U.S. has been.
I guess you could say the word is blessed
with very low inflation for a long time, steady
but low inflation, the way most economists
believe is ideal for an economy.
And we'll talk about why a little bit later.
The consumer price index has now increased
in April compared to a year earlier by four
point two percent.
And this is the most in a year over year comparison
dating all the way back to September of 2008.
So in about 13 years, when we compare one
month in one year to that same month, the
year before, this is the biggest change we've
seen about in the last 13 years.
Economists surveyed by Dow Jones were looking
for an increase of three point six percent.
It came in above that at four point two percent.
Now, this is really, really important to understand.
Before we even get into the macroeconomic
analysis, I do think we are seeing some prices
truly increase in some areas.
Lumber, for example, as far as the research
I've done shows lumber is getting more expensive
in a real way, not just because of a pandemic
related statistical artifact, but much of
this increase is merely a pandemic related
statistical artifact.
Gas prices, for example, going up in late
2020 and so far in 2021, aside from this temporary
pipeline shutdown, which is being resolved,
is back on.
As of today, we saw one of the biggest demand
collapses for gasoline in 2020 because the
country shut down, people weren't driving,
people weren't commuting.
And then relative to that, we saw a huge demand
increase later in 2020 and particularly in
2021.
So the numbers we just received for inflation
are April of twenty twenty one compared to
April of twenty twenty.
In April of twenty twenty, we had one of the
biggest macroeconomic demand collapses in
a very long time.
I can't I don't remember when we had such
a demand collapse because it was the first
full month of covid shutdown.
So prices collapsed.
Now we are comparing to April of twenty twenty.
And so when you look at the internals of what's
driving this price increase, its energy prices,
again, hugely demand driven oil prices collapsed
in the second quarter of twenty twenty, where
at one point oil futures had even gone negative.
Now people want to travel again.
People want to drive.
People want to fly.
Used car and truck prices are up, which makes
sense as some people are going back to commuting
one car.
Families are going back to two cars.
All of the people who got there first who
would have gotten their first jobs and potentially
gotten a car during the pandemic, but were
either working from home or didn't even get
that first job until now.
Many of them now need vehicles to start getting
to and from work.
So this is primarily what we call a base rate
effect when we compare inflation last month
to inflation at a time when lots of prices
had collapsed, you are going to see a relative
price increase that may not really be representative
of what is going on in the economy.
Now, the good news is that the Fed seems to
know this and has said we're not going to
do anything in the immediate as a result of
these inflation numbers.
One month of numbers with the heart of the
pandemic as the base number that we're comparing
to April of twenty twenty, it really doesn't
give you much to work with.
The inflation target remains two percent for
the year.
The Fed still expects that yearly inflation
year over year will be roughly two percent.
So for now, the Fed isn't going to raise rates.
They're not going to make any other changes.
Now, that all being said.
There are actual shortages of some construction
materials that will probably remain for the
foreseeable future, and that's going to cost
more.
Renovations are going to cost more.
New home prices may well cost more.
Now, let me address a couple of other bigger
picture things.
First, you might be saying, David, sir, why
is the target two percent inflation like?
Why is some inflation better than none?
Shouldn't we be targeting zero inflation?
This is a very debated economic issue.
But fundamentally, if you have deflation or
you have stagnant prices, meaning no change
whatsoever, it's an incentive for people to
wait to purchase things.
Now, this is a standard economic analysis.
If you want to apply a totally different line
of thinking to the economy, a more socialistic
line of thinking communistic, of course, you're
going to have a different perspective.
But in the kind of traditional economic thinking,
which is, of course, only partially right,
we know now that classical economics is only
tells part of the story.
The idea is, if you think things will cost
more in the future, you are incentivized to
buy them now before the prices go up.
You get it for less now and you can start
using it now.
Why would you wait?
That is where growth and employment and wages
come from.
If you think things will be cheaper in the
future, or at least that they won't be more
expensive, you might wait to see if prices
go down and then it creates a deflationary
spiral because you're waiting to buy.
Prices do go down.
Businesses have to lay people off since they're
not selling stuff because remember, you're
waiting to buy.
They don't have the employees that get laid
off, don't have money to buy stuff.
So prices go down more and you can have what's
called a deflationary spiral.
Japan experienced this for a long period of
time.
It's neoclassical at basic economic thinking,
but that's part of the working theory.
Obviously, too much inflation is bad because
then people's purchasing power goes down.
They can't afford stuff either.
So that's where you get to this kind of happy
medium of we want a little bit of inflation
and predictably so.
Now, last thing on this, Republicans are now
claiming vindication.
We told you the stimulus would make prices
go up and things would get unaffordable.
They said this one, Biden did the one point
nine trillion dollar stimulus.
They didn't say this when Trump did both of
his stimulus packages.
They have been saying it for thirty years,
including in 2009 when Obama did TARP, et
cetera, et cetera.
The truth is inflation.
Throughout all of that, government spending
has been very well controlled and very modest
and very reasonable.
This seems to be primarily an artifact of
comparing numbers to the absolute lul, the
doldrums of the pandemic.
And that's it.
There's really I'm finding myself not even
really having more to say about that piece
because it is so transparently untrue.
So that's the latest on inflation.
We'll watch the numbers.
We will soon have numbers in early June.
We'll have numbers comparing May twenty, twenty
one to May, twenty twenty.
And then we'll have to at that point, we'll
be able to get a more well rounded picture
of what's
going on.